hello and welcome to my image
recognition and image manipulation
tutorial series the series is just going
to be a simple introduction to the field
and the procedures used in those two
things initially it was mostly just for
image recognition but then some of the
stuff that we're doing in these earlier
videos you would also do if you wanted
to do image manipulation so image
recognition obviously views like a
screen reader like an OCR so an optical
character recognition program they would
use some image recognition for each
character and there's also a whole bunch
of like facial recognition and stuff
that you would use image recognition for
and then as far as image manipulation if
you think about like automatic image
enhancers they're basically doing this
right so like that kind of stuff will be
covered here obviously we won't be doing
facial recognition or image automatic
image enhancements right out of the gate
but we'll cover a lot of the basics for
the procedures so to start the series
you're going to need five things the
first thing we're going to get is this
zip file with a bunch of images in it
that we can use that I'll be using
throughout this series some text is my
website so you just go sent Dexcom slash
and then tutorial images that zip one
word hit enter and you should download
this tutorial images that zip file and
I'll just bring it up show you what it
is in the inside you have a file or a
folder called images extract this to
wherever you'll be writing this script
we'll get back to that in a little bit
and inside images you've got numbers and
then you've got some other images one's
just a single dot and other one's got a
dot and another dot this is my logo and
then only thin numbers we've got a bunch
of numbers and then an example of each
so like these are all zeros these are
all ones these are all twos and so on so
we'll get to those a little bit but
that's that's what's in the file now the
next thing that we're going to need is
Python we're going to be using the
programming language of Python to do all
of this Python is very newbie friendly
the syntax for programming in Python is
very simple there's
not too much you don't have to worry
about brackets all this kind of stuff
and the indentations automatic just very
friendly language yet very very powerful
for data analysis so that's what I
recommend you get it's definitely a good
programming language to learn if you
don't already know it I imagine a lot of
people watching these have seen my other
videos and probably already have Python
but if you don't go to download and wait
we one is down a Python 2.7 point 5
don't download Python 3 get to 7 and
download you know whatever operating
system you have is just gonna vary if
you do have Windows I highly suggest you
get the 64 bit version if you have a 64
bit version of Windows subsequently the
next three things we need are numpy
matplotlib and pil and pil stands for
python imaging the library now if you've
downloaded in anything like sy PI for
example a lot of times I'll come like
bundled with all of this stuff so you
might already have some of this stuff so
just try to do import numpy import
matplotlib import pil and see if you can
now if you have a 64 bit version of
python you can't use pil you'll be using
pillow and that's actually what i'll be
using throughout this series and since i
recommend that everyone gets 64 bit if
you're on Windows I highly suggest you
get a 64 bit and don't worry about not
being able to get pil otherwise ever all
the downloads will be here I use this
website lfd whatever so let me copy and
copy this real quick if you come up here
it's basically a bunch of these windows
binaries for Python and they're just
like straight installers instead of
having you setup dot exe or and I'm
sorry nuts setup that pi so like setup
tools or pip install and all that so
again very new friendly to come here and
you just download the Installer so like
for example with pillow I'll put all
these links in the description but if
you use my link it should take you all
the way down here you would download
whatever version you need if you're on
Windows and obviously if you're on like
Linux or something like that then you'll
need to just find a pillow install and
install install any stuff on
Linux is pretty simple so you need this
but anyway
same thing with numpy if you're on
Windows download the numpy version and
then a matplotlib download the version
that you need again if you have 64-bit
make sure you get all the 64-bit if
you're on 32-bit make sure the Installer
you download is that win32 and so on so
once you have all five of those things
let's go ahead and make sure we have all
five of those things before moving on
one check to make sure you got that
download the tutorial images zip
download to make sure you've got Python
and you installed it so if you did you
should be able to go to your Start bar
if you're on Windows and type in Python
and you should be able to get something
called Python and then in parenthesis
it'll say command line pull that up drag
that over and it probably will be black
with white text but it'll look something
like this and if you ever if you don't
know what bit version you downloaded you
can scroll over here and it should say
like right here like what bit version
you have now the next thing that we're
gonna want to do to make sure that we
got everything downloaded and installed
correctly you're gonna want to import
each of the things so if you are if you
installed a numpy you should be able to
go import numpy without any errors and
on air is gonna look like this so let's
say we actually spelled numpy right but
we get this error no module that means
it something went wrong in the
installation usually the issue that my
viewers have is they just downloaded the
wrong bit version so that's pretty much
it anyway moving on import matplotlib no
error and you should finally be able to
import well if you if you have a 32-bit
version of python then the you will be
importing PIL and I happen to have PIL
but actually for this tutorial we're not
gonna be using PIL well depending on
what you have anyway
if you had PIL you would just do import
image like that but if you downloaded
pillow you will do just import PIL but
we'll get to that in just a second but
as long as you could do if you have
let me let me say it one more time
before we go on if you have a 32-bit
version of Python make sure you can do
import capital ima GE and if you have a
64-bit version of Python make sure you
can download or import PIL and then more
importantly make sure you can do from
PIL import capital I am a GE hit enter
okay so as long as everything is working
up to that point then you've installed
everything and you're ready to go to the
next video as always thanks for watching